[Musique]
dit la chanson alors que le président
américain entre en scène à Varsovie
l'ambiance est festive comme si la
victoire était à portée de main et la
situation n'a jamais été aussi tendue
entre Washington et Moscou
les autocrates comprennent qu'un seul
mot dit Joe Biden c'est non non vous ne
pouvez pas envahir un pays prendre leur
liberté l'Ukraine ne sera jamais une
victoire pour la Russie
il ajoute que Washington imposera de
nouvelles sanctions contre la Russie
Vladimir Poutine ne semble pas avoir
digéré la visite de Joe Biden la veille
à Kiev une preuve de plus selon lui que
Washington se sert de l'Ukraine pour
détruire la Russie
la situation c'est tellement dégradée
dit-il que la Russie suspend sa
participation au traité dilatéral
newsportt sur le contrôle de l'arsenal
nucléaire signé en 2010
les deux pays contrôlent 90% des armes
nucléaires dans le monde
les Nations Unies sonnent l'alarme
dit-il et bien plus dangereux et
instable avec des conséquences
potentiellement catastrophiques
le discours à la nation de Vladimir
Poutine est projetée sur des écrans
géants car leur est grave à la Douma
selon lui il y va de l'avenir du pays
avant même notre opération spéciale
dit-il l'Ouest fournissait des armes à
l'Ukraine le président russe tient les
États-Unis et l'OTAN responsable du
conflit en Ukraine ils veulent détruire
la Russie dit-il comme ils l'ont fait en
Irak en Libye en Yougoslavie
nous ne voulons ni contrôler ni détruire
la Russie réitère Joe Biden à lui seul
ajout-il Poutine pourrait arrêter la
guerre
les discours fusent mais en Ukraine ce
sont les bombes la ville de Kerson est
attaquée alors que l'homme fort du
Kremlin prononçait son discours
pour la Russie l'OTAN est en train de
gruger dans sa sphère d'influence en
Europe de l'Est 17 expert et tendre
l'OTAN à sa frontière ça ne va pas bien
se terminer
aujourd'hui la rencontre du chef de la
diplomatie chinoise et son homologue
russe Sergueï Lavrov à Moscou nous
montre aucun signe de détente
ici Radio-Canada Washington
[Musique]